the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like there is some
shocking news in regards to the game of
thrones veteran director and house of
the dragon showrunner miguel sapochnick
according to a brand new article
released only yesterday there is a
massive shakeup within house of the
dragon as one of its showrunners walks
away from the hit series now for those
of you who might not know miguel is best
known for his work on game of thrones as
the director of some of its greatest
episodes like heart home battle of the
bastards and the winds of winter after
having such massive success on game of
thrones hbo brought him on to work on
their new series house of the dragon as
one of the show runners alongside ryan
condole he also directed house of the
dragon's first episode as well as a few
others that will be released later this
season unfortunately it looks like he
will be stepping down as house of the
dragon showrunner according to the new
article sources say miguel is leaving
the show after an exhausting three years
of work went into the game of thrones
series how so the dragon co-creator ryan
condell will now serve as the show's
head showrunner and continue to work
with co-creator george rr martin it says
that miguel has also entered into a
first look deal with hbo to develop
other shows and he will remain as
executive producer for the duration of
the series i really hope this means
miguel will still direct at least one
episode in the final season ever since i
heard miguel would be working on house
of the dragon i was really hoping he
would be the one who directed the
episode that will feature an incredible
dragon battle over the god's eye now i
won't go into exactly what that means in
case some of you don't want to know but
if you've read fire and blood you know
exactly what i mean and you know that
episode will most likely be one of the
greatest episodes in all of the game of
thrones in house of the dragon i thought
miguel was exactly who he would need for
that episode because he's always been
known for directing some of game of
thrones greatest battles i'm guessing
making this show must be a lot harder
than any of us have imagined i know it
wasn't easy for him to walk away from a
series that will most likely be one of
the biggest shows within the next few
years now the good news is hbo has hired
another game of thrones veteran to fill
his spot on house of the dragon alan
taylor who also directed many game of
thrones episodes will now step in to
direct several episodes during house of
the dragon's second season for those of
you who don't know allen actually
directed nearly half of game of thrones
second season which if you ask me is one
of the better seasons of the show he
also directed one of my favorite
episodes baylor when ned stark was
executed in the first season when he
gave a statement about joining house of
the dragon he said it's an honor to be
back at hbo immersing myself into the
world of the targaryens ryan miguel and
george have created an extraordinary
story in a rich and fascinating world
going back to westeros will be a massive
undertaking and i'm looking forward to
the challenge well alan all i can say is
welcome back to westeros i hope you're
able to bring back some of the magic you
brought to game of thrones now i think i
speak for most fans when i say those
were some of the best years on the show
it is sad that miguel is leaving house
of the dragon anyone who has been
watching my videos over the last few
years knows exactly how excited i was
when it was announced that he would be
joining the show although he is leaving
i do look forward to seeing the other
episodes he did direct for this season
hopefully the door will still be open
for him in the future if he eventually
does decide he would like to direct
another episode for house of the dragon
again
as always let me know what you think
about this new information do any of you
think this will negatively affect the
show leave me your thoughts down below i
want to thank all of you for stopping by
and watching the short update video i
hope you all have a great day i will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you